in this video we're going to get our
bearings on the different types of
studies you might statistically analyze
or statistical studies
so first of all it's worth
differentiating between
an experiment and
an observational study i encourage you
pause this video
and think about what the difference is
at least in your head between an
experiment
and an observational observational
study well
you might already be familiar with
experiments you often times have a
hypothesis
that if you do something to one group
that it might have
some type of statistically significant
impact on them relative to a group that
you did not do it
to and you would be generally right that
is the flavor of what we're talking
about when we're talking about an
experiment
an experiment we're actively putting
people or things
into a control versus treatment group in
the
treatment group you put the people and
you usually would want to randomly
select people into the treatment group
maybe it's a new type of medication
and maybe in the treatment group they
actually get the medication
while in the control group which you
would put people into
randomly whether they're in control or
treatment
here they might get a placebo where they
get a pill that looks just like the
medication but it really doesn't do
anything
and then you wait some time and you can
see is very statistically significant
difference between the treatment group
on average and
the control group so that's what an
experiment does it's kind of this active
sorting and figuring out whether some
type of
stimulus is able to show a difference
while an observational study you don't
actively
put into groups instead you just collect
data and see if you can have some
insights
from that data if you can say okay the
data there's a
population here can i come up with some
statistics that are indicative of the
population i might just want to look at
averages
or i might want to find some
correlations between
variables but even when we're talking
about an observational study
there are different types of it
depending on what type of data we're
looking at
whether the data is backward looking
forward looking or it's data that we are
collecting
right now based on what people think or
say
right now so if we're thinking about an
observational study that is looking at
past
data and i could imagine doing something
like this at khan academy where we could
look at
maybe usage of khan academy over time we
have these things in our server logs
and we're able to make do some analysis
there maybe we're able to analyze and
say okay
on average students are spending two
hours
per month on khan academy over
in 2019 that would be past data
and that type of observational study
would be called a
retrospective study retro
for backwards and spective
looking so a retrospective observational
study
would sample past data in order to come
up with some insights
now you could imagine there might be the
other side what if we are
trying to observe things into the future
well here you might take a sample of
folks who you think are indicative of a
population
and you might want to just track their
data so you could even consider that to
be
future data so you pick the group the
sample ahead of time
and then you track their data over time
i'm just going to draw it as these
little
arrows that you're tracking their data
and then you see what happens
for example you might randomly select
hopefully a random sample
of a hundred women and you want to see
in the coming year how many eggs
do they eat on average per day well what
you would do is
you selected those folks and then you
would track that data for each of them
every day
and then once you have the data you
could actually do it while you're
collecting it
but at the end of the study you'll be
able to see what those averages are but
you can also keep track of it
while you're taking that data and you
could imagine what this
is called instead of retrospective we're
now looking forward so it is
pro-spective forward
looking observational study last but not
least some of y'all are probably
thinking
what about if we're doing something now
if we go
out there and we were to survey a bunch
of people
and say how many eggs did you eat today
or
who are you going to vote for what might
we call that
was tempting to call it something with a
prefix and inspective so it all matches
but it turns out that the terminology
that statisticians will typically use
is a sample survey sample
survey that right now you're going to
take a
hopefully random sample of individuals
from the population that you care about
and you are just going to survey them
right now and ask them say
some questions or observe some data
about them
right now so i'll leave you there this
video is to just give you a little bit
of the
vocabulary and a little bit of a
taxonomy on the types of studies that
you'll see in general
which is especially useful to know when
you're exploring the world of statistics